hello everyone and welcome to the final
round of the 2008 in European club cup
its Peter Svidler vs. Magnus Carlsen on
board 1 and well the outcome of this
match on all of the six boards will
largely impact the outcome of the entire
2018 a European cloth cup so without
further ado let's check out their scores
before this encounter so before this
encounter Peter Svidler has beaten
Magnus Carlsen two-to-one in classical
chess with 14 rows but if we consider
faster time controls than Magnus Carlsen
has beaten Peter Svidler 11 to 7 with 24
draws so a very nice opportunity for
Carlsen to equalize this score even
though with the black pieces and we
don't have a nice photo by Nicky Riga
from from this matchup there you have it
before the start of the game a lot of
people in the crowd and also one
gentleman taking either a shot or some
nice video we don't have any video
footage from this round as Nicky says it
was a pretty crazy round for not really
sure what she meant by that but
apparently it was really crazy but for
free to follow her on all of our social
media the links will be in the
description below also follow chasing
Ricci Tube channel they always have a
lot of impressions with a lot of video
footage from every round so I will also
put a link to that in the description
below feel free to enjoy that as well so
now without further ado silver has the
white pieces and he opens with E for
Carlsen opens with c6 we have d4 and d5
and it's very interesting sorry about
that that on all of the six boards as a
swindler steam is higher rated on every
board except on this one where of course
causing his fire rated as he is the
highest rated player in the world the
caro-kann is on the board in 92 d
captures only 4/9 captures on e4 and now
Knight to f6 this is the mainline Knight
captures we have it captures on f6 and
the now c3 further strengthening the
center Bishop to d6 by Carlsen and
Bishop to d3 we have castles and Queen
to c2 and here Carlsen plays rook to e8
check leeches posted on
Twitter that Causton already played this
position in one bullet game and leeches
against the GM the warning so I thought
that was that was pretty funny
okay brush up to e3 blocking check and
now h6 as the h7 point was under attack
Knight to e2 preparing the castle and
now comes knife to a 6 here Carlson is
preparing to bring the knight over to c7
and although it seems like you could
capture the night here and the mess of a
black's pawn structure you won't really
gain anything here after be capped
resigning 6 yes you have messed up a
black structure a bit but where are you
gonna Castle if you Castle queenside
then black has a semi-open a B file for
his rook and if you decide to Castle
kingside then black will put a bishop on
b7 and with with the bishop repair it
will be a very dangerous position to
play for black so nothing really to gain
from this after Knights to a 6 we have
castles and here comes knife to c7 s
planned C for my sweater as now this
takes away the B and the D 5 squares
squares from the knight and also keeps a
very nice control of the central squares
and Bishop to g4 Carlsen develops his
Bishop h3 as fiddler asks what are your
plans with this bishop of course you
don't really have the option of going
Bishop to h5 as the Queen and Bishop
regarding g6 twice if you will have to
retreat so here Carlson's idea was the
capture here and it's a very interesting
what do you capture with the bishop or
with the Queen if you capture with the
Queen this isn't so great because now
black has this a very nice option of
strengthening his position with the g6
and of course you cannot capture on h6
because you would lose your queen and
now black will at some point play King
g7 + f5 and all will be well for black
so in fact the Bishop captures an e2 is
the better idea now of course g6 makes
no sense white and simply capture it so
Knights the e6 we have rook a to d1
developing the rook Queen to c7
developing the Queen also connecting
rooks Bishop to g4 and now comes the
rook a to d8
rook F to e 1 and here Bishop to f4 by
Carlsen offering a trade of bishops as
wiggler except
Bishop captures we have night captures
on f4 and now comes rope captures on e8
rook captures an e 8 and now h4 if you
play something other than h4 h4 is the
strongest move here if you play
something like b3 for example to
strengthen your queen side then black
can play h5 himself and after Bishop
gave f3 you can go Queen to c8 and then
well regardless of what white plays it
like and get a very nice attack with
with the g5 and g 4 and so on
so spiller decided to play h4 himself
now
g5 will not be all that impressive
because if h5 now Bishop to f3 and g5
you can simply play g3 attacking the
knight here and after something like g4
attacking the bishop or two g2
characters characters and now the the
structure here is fixed and ok cousin -
f - f point so he will probably try to
break through here at some point but you
know there's no reason to do this
whittler decides to play this and cross
someplace Queen to a5 a very nice move
as it attacks dat pawn but also controls
the e1 square that's the rock is on so
look to e1 check it's definitely a move
that will happen at some point with a g3
again the best move are kicking away the
night and also making some more
breathing space for the king f5 a nice
in-between move by Carlson and now
Bishop to f3 you don't gain anything by
playing something like G captures on f4
f captures and then d5 would be very
dangerous if rope to d8 then even
captures on c6 captures and now rope
characters Queen captures and although
this would be playable
there's no reason to risk it you do have
a nice bishop here so why not keep it
Bishop to f3 by sailor and now rook to
e1 check as crossing the plate Queen to
a5 to prepare this King to h2 definitely
the best move if you try something like
rook captures an a1
after about that Haruka is anyone a
Queen captures
anyone with check and now King to h2 now
you get this very dangerous nice to e6
move
and it's not possible to both guard the
d4 pawn and also guarded df2 pawn the
Queen can guard ef-2 pawn but it's very
hard to guard the d4 pawn you would have
to put d5 here and now nice to d4 will
win you the game for black as again you
can't protect your bishop here and also
protect the DF to pawn you might play
something like Queen to d3 now comes
Queen captures on f2 and after you play
this now you can simply push g5 and
there is no stopping g4 and Knight to f3
this will be this will be winning for
black one such variation could be
captures captures and after a white
tries d6 King to f8 will be sufficient
to stop the advance of the D pawn and
whatever white plays g4 is coming Queen
to f1 Knight to f3 check King here Queen
captures and now whatever you play
Bishop captures pawn captures white will
be without a move for the rest of the
game as he will always have to keep an
eye on this Queen - G - checkmate and it
will be an easy win for black so after
Luke to e1 check King to h2 by Sadler
rook captures on d1
King capture somebody won and now comes
Knight to g6 now Knights the e6 wouldn't
be all that impressive because now d5
would be somewhat dangerous after C
capture see captures no Knight has to
move knife to f8 already d6 is coming
and comes with an attack against this
pawn so would be a very dangerous
position for black so Crossing goes
Knight to g6 would the idea of going
night to f8 to d7 a3 finally fiddler has
to guarded the a to pawn and now comes
f4 as DF bonds are doubled why not waste
one to break open Svidler skiing side we
have B 24 and now comes F captures on g3
with Czech pawn captures and g3 and now
Knight to f8 Michaelson not allowing any
any captures and the doubling of the
pawns and also the night will be a very
useful piece to defend the advance of
the D pawn slit or does push d5 we have
C cap force on d5 and now although other
captures are possible CID or decides the
trade Queen's here Queen captures and
cross and accepts as there is no better
move here Queen captures
Bishop captures and now comes the b6 you
have to guard the pawn and now b4 as
wheeler would very much enjoy creating a
passport here with c5 so Crossin
prevents it nice to d7 and we have King
to g2 enough silver wants to bring his
King into the game and Carson does the
same as it's the endgame you do have to
use your king a king to f2 Knight to f6
now and now Bishop to f3 again we have
this very nice mutual encounter between
the bishop and the night where they
control each other's squares King to e7
a king to III King to d6 and King to d4
now the Kings are in opposition nice the
g8 we have c5 check out we have captures
captures as we learn now creates a past
see pawn king to c7 and Bishop to d5 now
attacking the f7 pawn this is move 39
cause some place in Knight to e7 for his
39th move and now as fiddler has to make
one more move to reach time control so
there are several options here if if you
captured upon then you get Knight to f5
would check and you're gonna lose the g3
pawn king e5 Knight captures and g3 so
not something you want to do with the
white wheeler
instead you could also play something
like h5 but then a similar variation
arises after Knight to a5 check King e5
Knight captures and g3 and only now
Bishop captures on f7 where you would
guard your h5 pawn but now I have to
king to c6 King to f4 now you can simply
capture with the night here and after
characters you can capture here and this
will be a force to draw at some point
you would try to protect your only pawn
if black manages to grab the a pond and
it will be a draw this Bishop to e2 move
it was very nice because it the Bishop
and pawn create a wall here against the
black king but black king will go simply
go underneath it acting to c3 and now
after a 4 you will either play Bishop to
d1 after which simply this and you at
some point the King will have to go for
the h6 pawn and then you will start
advancing your jeep on and when the
point comes to g4 Bishop will capture it
and then you will win this pawn and it
will be a draw
on the other hand if you don't go Bishop
here if you go Bishop to b5 a similar
idea h5 and now after King attacks at g6
and the area is the same you all seem to
capture with the King here and now after
this pawn starts advancing you will
simply have to position your Bishop to
capture it and only then will it be
actually a four pawn and to draw the
game so pretty much a drawn variation
this h5 idea so similar goes for King to
e5 on his 40th move to reach time
control cross and snatches the Bishop
Knight capture screen captures and now
we have h5 and OKC six we have a six by
cross and a four and now a five trying
to force a White's to move the King so
King to c5 getting opposition and now
comes f6 we have King to d5 and now g5
of course if you try something like H
captures and g5 then F captors and g5
will be winning for black this creates a
very dangerous pass pawn and this will
will in fact be a very very fast born so
you will not be able to temperament him
from queening after g5 would have King
to e6 and vice whittler going after the
f6 pawn we have captures captures
characters captures and here we have
this very interesting endgame position a
very symmetrical position and it's very
interesting what do you play here after
after this G captures on h4 what does
black play here so feel free to pause
the video here and try to continue this
game for black just to try and get the
sense of the position I'll give you a
couple of seconds if you want to decide
whether to do it or not for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are truly an excellent and game
player and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show you can play king
d 17 t 6 king b5 but if you try king c5
to go after this pawn on a4 you will
lose the game because after King to g5
came to b4 and you will not be able to
snatch the point-in-time captures
captures and now you will get a similar
position like I like from the movie
searching for Bobby Fischer well it will
not come with check both players will
Queen but now Queen captures Queen as
they are both winning on this diagonal
so very interesting stuff
but okay if you go anywhere on the other
side for example came to d6 like the
move that was played in the game then
you will be able you will not lose this
game a king to g5 king to e5 will have
King captures and now King to f5 King to
h6 King to f6 we have h5 came to f7 and
now the King escapes but now comes King
g7 we have h6 with check King moves and
now King to h5 king moves king comes to
g6 King g8 and now comes a 7 and after
King to h8 the players agreed to a draw
it seems like like a weird position for
you to draw the game as you are up upon
and perhaps you can even start running a
way to grab this point in Queen but you
will not be in time for example if you
do if you in fact try this for example
the 5 king of 5b v King e5 King b5 we
need if I mention captures you will
simply block off the king and the king
will not be able you will create a wall
against the white king and the White
King will not be able to push you away
at one point the White King will have to
move and now you will occupy the 8
square and there is no more waste the
Queen de-spawn now I've got a couple of
moves you will either have to move your
king and allow black to capture this
pawn or you will play King to a6 and now
it will be a stalemate so of course they
knew this after this King - h8 move by
Carlsen acid and coughs and decided I'll
draw the game and it seems the Svidler
will keep his positive score against
caution for yet another encounter and
cost and we refer for not losing this
game will keep his number 1 his position
as the number one rated chess player in
the world and I don't think he will be
playing any more radio games before he
faces Fabiano so in the match against
Fabiana Caruana in November my cousin
will still be the highest rated player
in the world so yeah that's the game I
do hope you enjoyed it hopefully it was
a it was a
educational endgame that whole that
whole King business like I said there
will be a lot of useful links in the
description below so feel free to follow
chess in Greece for free
to follow an inky rig on all of her
social media you know just check it out
and feel free to enjoy it I would like
to thank France hill but host powell mo
Moro miles Heyford and Ian Fowler for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check - on my previous
videos your thing called for watching
and I'll see you soon
hopefully with some more interesting
content I don't know who the winner of
the European Club Cup is as some of the
games were still being played but
cousins well a ring a team did I believe
they haven't win because one of their
boards barkeeper de vich blundered a
piece somewhere around moved 25 so it
was a pretty big ball for them and the
news Greendale is lost this game so
basically that's it you know follow all
of their social media for further
updates think'll for watching and see
you soon are most likely continuing the
Bobby Fischer series season